christian estrosi le mouvement la
française a été lancée en 2010 elle
s'était pas trompé en politique un
détection des manuels maintenant qu'elle
est le tremblement terre sociale ou
sanitaire qui vous conduit aujourd'hui à
le transformer en mouvement politique
je crois que la crise yacco vide et
notamment dès le printemps dernier a
démontré quel point le gouvernement
était démuni et dépourvu dans des
compétences qui sont pleinement les
siennes et qui aux trois quarts pourtant
d'été assumé par les collectivités
locales à leur initiative sans esprit
polémique dans un mouvement d'unité
nationale mais qui a été un révélateur
le révélateur selon lequel aujourd'hui
si on le décentralise pas plus si on ne
partage pas plus de prérogatives entre
le gouvernement et les collectivités
nous ne répondrons pas dans les
principaux domaines où les français ont
des attentes que ça touche à
l'insécurité que ça touche à la
transition écologique que ça touche à la
cohésion sociale
ça touche à l'emploi ces attentes qui
moment d'une crise sanitaire qui sans
doute sera bousculée violemment dans les
semaines à venir par une crise
économique et crise sociale qui va
redoubler importance voilà c'est un
message aussi adressé qui a vocation à
fédérer des milliers de citoyens qui se
reconnaissent plus dans l'action que
nous venons sur les territoires
que dans les grandes réformes nationales
qui ont de moins en moins de lisibilité
dans cette bâtisse où ils veulent se
faire des tableaux des capelles disait
cette phrase au fond quand on est sur le
terrain on comprend pas de posture
politique c'est un peu votre une fois ce
que vous payez reprendre ou pas je
relève que la plupart des maires
sortants qui ont été largement réélu au
mois de mars au printemps dernier l'ont
été sur la base de listes de dépassement
de rassemblement naturellement ou sont
écartés les extrêmes mais où on voit
bien que la recherche est toujours de
permettre le grand nombre de
représentations de nos concitoyens par
rapport à leur expérience leur vécu
d'être là pour mieux répondre aux
attentes quotidiennes
on est la france du quotidien il faut
une égalité entre l'exécutif et les
collectivités locales c'est quand même
un tremblement terre institutionnel
c'est quand même parce que on voit bien
le 18 avec les partis politiques qu'ils
allaient crise on compte ni des
élections législatives partielles des
prépensions de votants c'est 80 % de ma
d'abstention participation
c'est peut-être aussi parce qu'on a le
sentiment que cette élection ne permet
pas quelqu'un de désigner quelqu'un qui
va peser sur l'action
aujourd'hui les français sont inquiets
la politique les agace pas ce qu'elle
paraît trop partisane trop politicienne
et donc qu'ils se reconnaissaient le
plus en ce qu'ils agissent en ce à la
porte desquelles ils peuvent frapper
dans ce qu'ils peuvent changer leur vie
et nous changeons leur vie
on voit la vie des français ne pas
changer pendant plusieurs gouvernements
d'affilée mais on voit ici ou là la vie
de citoyens d'une ville d'un village
changer parce que d'importants
changements sont opérés à l'initiative
de son maire et de ses élus locaux donc
on est cette france qui peut à partir de
ces territoires
si demain il ya ce respect et cette
considération où nous sommes des
représentants de la nation pas plus mais
pas moins que les parlementaires et que
nous ne sommes pas dans le commentaire
mais dans l'action qui peut permettre à
la france de gagner les points de
croissance de pib qui lui font défaut
une dernière question politique là vous
avez vous même
les positions pour emmanuel macron en
tout cas vous avez appelé le candidat
est ce que ça c'est une position
personnelle c'est position qui engage la
france audacieuse puisque la france
annonce qu'elle regroupe des gens qu'ils
sont de sensibilité différente qu'ils
ont des parties ou pas le choix dit que
pas vous dire que le débat sur les
présidentielles est prématuré énerve les
français que la france audacieuse est
tout sauf une écurie présidentielle et
rentrer dans ce débat que je dise
aujourd'hui que dans les moments de
crise il doit y avoir un dépassement et
le volonté de rassemblement
mais où chacun de son côté doit faire un
pas en avant pour le permettre c'est une
chose
après vous dire ce que je ferai dans
deux ans c'est autre chose
mais aujourd'hui je n'ai pas apporté de
soutien conditionnel et de même que je
n'ai pas de réponse
car ce que je souhaite c'est voir la
france gouvernée par la droite et le
centre
dans cet esprit de dépassement et de
rassemblement et que naturellement
chacun doit se prononcer je n'ai pas
entendu toutes les réponses
c'est à dire merci beaucoup christian
estrosi